a friendly reminder to all foundation  staff dr bright is not a superhero of  any sort head of public relations in  charge of orientation for new staff a  doctor of psychology a member of site  command made out of bacon in possession  of an iq over 300 head of scp review or  a member of maintenance staff  sorry boys dr bright is a member of site  command it's usually best not to ask why  it's o5 command you're thinking of given  that he's constantly taking other  people's bodies to propagate himself  it's no surprise that dr bright might be  a little prone to the occasional  identity crisis this is however no  excuse for him to confuse others though  especially new recruits by claiming to  have seemingly every title under the sun  except his own possessing the body of a  doctor of psychology does not mean that  the title passes to you dr bright this  isn't highlander